jetzt ist das nur aktionen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
leute ich warte joggen jetzt habe ich
schnell geduscht und ich werde immer
nervöser und das heißt nervöser also ist
irgendwie sondern auch lustiges gefühl
kann man sagen ich stelle mal kurz die
kamera hier auf meine kaffeemaschine
leute und es war eine sache
ich kann ich bin jetzt schon sicher das
wird auf jeden fall eines der heftigsten
videos auf diesem kanal einfach weil der
wirt das machen außer ich meine ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass rebecca
bringen sich die haare abschneidet
können ein bisschen dramatische musik
haben also leute wie gesagt oder ich
habe es doch gar nicht sagt
wahrscheinlich am titel schon gelesen
heute bekomme ich besuche eigentlich
wollte ich das in einem friseurladen
machen aber ich habe mir gedacht es wäre
super cuda dass ihr zu machen und zwar
kommt gleich einen friseur zu mir der
überhaupt keine ahnung hat was ihn
erwartet und meine aufgabe fliegen ist
eigentlich ganz einfach wer richtig cool
verpasst mir doch einfach die frisur die
duh bei den zielkunden ja das ist ganz
wichtig wenn die kunden geschnitten hat
ich hoffe mal das geht ohne probleme und
ich bin wirklich gespannt wie ich danach
aussehe
ich denke mir halt wirklich erich laub
schon so lange so rum was neues wir auch
mal cool
darum geht es heute in diesem video und
erst muss ich mich erst mal noch ein
bisschen ausholen
so leute also der länder ist jetzt da es
geht und da scheint mir jetzt vielleicht
die haare
ich würde sagen wir wollen erstmal in
ruhe und dann können wir ja mal dann
erkläre ich dass meine idee ist weise
und dann bin ich mal gespannt wie ich
nach heraus
also du brauchst eine fertigung in den
körper kann hier sein koffer habe ich
noch nie gesehen jetzt wird er hier
schon besser geworden
mit licht und ein ich hole mal kurz ein
kabel stellt jetzt wieder so ein spiegel
aufgebaut kommen so was habe ich noch
nie gesehen das war alles im koffer mit
drin in diesem koffer wirklich alles
drin also was das hier so auch so farbe
und so
das sind stylingprodukte von garrel
gerne mit denen arbeitet zusammen konnte
legen also leute noch sehen meine haare
so aus ganz normal so wie ihr das alter
gewohnheit
ich würde sagen ich mach mal kurz vorher
nachher video damit wir das am ende noch
mal also damit man noch mal diesen
unterschied sieht je nachdem was meinen
haaren gleich passieren wird und dann
sehen wir uns wieder wenn es losgeht die
sind auf jeden fall schon wieder
ziemlich lang geworden meine haare
wachsen echt schnell weise also ich habe
vor eineinhalb wochen erst beim friseur
und die waren echt kurz das heißt wenn
ich mir jetzt gar nicht zu mir passt es
nicht so schlimm weil ich schnell
nachwächst
so leute ich hoffe wir haben nicht gut
jetzt kann es losgehen
ich muss jetzt erst mal die idee
erklären jetzt also wenn man es alles
aufgebaut ich habe so ein format das
habe ich irgendwann mal angefangen
letzten da geht es darum dass sich halt
genau das mache wie die person vor mir
also als beispiel bei saturn beitrittes
und da muss ich genau das recht kaufen
wie die person vor mir und ich habe ein
kommentar bekommen dass ich das auch
einfach mal mit meinen haaren machen
soll weise also
praktisch deine aufgabe wäre dass du mir
meine haare so schneider am besten ohne
dass ich es weiß wie der letzte
männliche kunde den ort ist weil ich bin
jetzt am wochenende eine woche ähnlichen
deutschland und von daher ist es mir
auch egal ob meine haare dann gut
aussehen oder ob es nicht so gut
aussieht weil wir haben schon darüber
gesprochen
die wachsen schnell nach denke ich eher
von daher war es ja auch keine sorgen
machen dass es vielleicht nicht so passt
aber so geht das passt denn das also war
es gibt ja viele verschiedene art habe
ich es selbst nicht du kannst wenn du
dein typ langer hat kannst du nicht mal
wir machen es nicht es kommt immer
darauf an was ein typ du bist die
gesichtsform es die haarstruktur ist
eine augen da achte ich schon sehr drauf
das ist okay aber das wie der
letztendliche kunde das klima hin wir
hatten nämlich ungefähr gleichen
haarschnitt ok also das klima in mit der
struktur so und so kriegen wir hin und
wieder ein anderer typ aber immerhin
und was hat er so ungefähr also ist es
kürzer wahrscheinlich nur er die seiten
sind von 0 gar den fake nach oben
hier oben in dem oberen bereich alles
kürzer flach liegen ja hat vorne einen
kleinen ponys und wie viel ist ungefähr
denn hier also habe ich dann also da
werde ich jetzt das kann nicht so jetzt
seid man nicht einschätzen aber da wird
schon einiges runterkommen hast du eine
kurzhaarfrisur
ok und mainz auch können wir
interessenten stehen ja dazu besonderen
trend wird so aus erinnert ok von daher
kann direkt an
da sind die fusion entnehmen ok dann was
machen was den wenigsten zumal sein wäre
das war ja der ist gehen wir auch leute
wenn ihr nicht kennen könnte einmal
googeln oder ich gute also vielleicht
sollte ich dann auch anfangen
dann sehen wir dann sagen auch wenn die
ergebnisse bäumen
ich habe wirklich schon gebe ich meine
hab einfach immer so ein bisschen sonne
strand und sonst man sieht immer gleich
aus willich heute.de der das mal ein
bisschen verändert ich hoffe ihr seid
mir nicht böse wenn ihr aus können
kommen wir so oder so ich weiß nicht
einmal kurz werbung für sich machen oder
ich kann ja in die infobox ein paar ein
paar kontakten zum gefragten gehen auch
sonst kann es auf jeden fall machen wind
seit zehn jahren machen mein beruf auch
so dementsprechend genau so lange zehn
jahren halt ständig unterwegs ich selber
arbeite keinen barbershop oder so wir
haben hauptsächlich nur für artists
künstler quasi für showbiz in dem
bereich tätig
bocker kann immer auch machen und sachen
welcher künstler heute morgen übermorgen
dann spielt man in so einer maschine
genau dann kann das ja mal checken
er hat vor allem viel zu hören ist auch
so finde ich wenn ihr die haare
schneiden dass so manche hardware nicht
meister aber das muss ich sagen ich muss
gar nicht sein hat es kommt immer darauf
an die man den umhang festmacht mehr als
krause vorher dann machten die hygiene
aber jetzt geht's los
das macht einfach weiter ist nur hier
unten hier wird weil ich okay schicken
wir mal das video meines schöne grüße so
leute die seiten sind jetzt schon mal
ziemlich cool wenn wir heute die es und
jetzt gehen wir bisher nach oben richtig
und dementsprechend lassen wir dann auch
sagen ja auch an
also ich muss sagen ich hatte meine
haare wirklich noch nie so kurz aber
erfüllt voll interessant also leute ich
würde mich richtig freuen wenn ihr mal
kurz bei instagram vorbeischaut da habe
ich nämlich auch ein foto mit der neuen
frisur gepostet könnt ihr sehr gerne
leiten und dort auch mal eure meinung
schreiben
danke
ein qualitäts standards was kameras
angeht so werden jetzt etwas kosten so
richtig krasse schweren stoff für 1000
euro ausführen oder meinte er hat damals
die kosten neu gekauft hat 15 15 die
hier ist bei 18 aber die geprüft 500 mal
in deutschland ich hätte die nummer 3
146 wenn ihr mal kaputt gesagt bestelle
ich auch noch papier schere zu ende aber
ich bin also ich muss sagen so dass für
uns eigentlich schlecht ist es auch
nicht also nein bei uns wir haben jetzt
ein klub ja was der klub der schmeckt
jetzt wirst du dir schmeckt jetzt wie es
geschmeckt jetzt teile sind hier noch
mal dafür benutzt so der das ist ein
richtig gutes produkt wie ist das in
solar von baurecht thaliana merkel und
ich hab ein kleines bisschen mehr
genommen als sonst damit das halt nicht
so schnell trocken dass leute wir machen
jetzt mal ein vorher nachher das
manchmal selber mal gespannt wie das
nachher aussieht also dieser vergleich
das
[Musik]
leute dann würde ich sagen machen wir
hier auch direkt das ende
also ich muss sagen mir persönlich
gefällt es gut ja ich glaube dass ich es
von tag zu tag besser finden werde
natürlich ist am anfang ein bisschen
ungewohnt schreibt mir sehr gerne eure
meinung dazu die kommentare würde mich
sehr interessieren und schreibt noch
weitere ideen für dieses format und in
die kommentare abonniert main kanal
glocke aktivieren würde ich mich sehr
darüber freuen und jack mines account
abchecken von lend ihr habt ist ein
richtig cooler friseur danke nochmal das
mitgemacht hast und ich sehe jetzt halt
aus wie ein rapper aber nicht vergessen